[Music]
I'm Louie and I'm engineer on the
Android toolkit team today I'm gonna be
sharing some best practices when using
the Android X preference library part of
jetpack I'm going to be covering some
background behind preferences and try to
clear up any confusion between
preferences and shared preferences I'll
demonstrate how to go to settings screen
and some useful features you can use
along the way and I'm going to cover how
you can use multiple settings screens
which is especially useful if you're
migrating your existing architecture to
the Android X library but first some
background what are preferences the
preference library is a framework for
building interactive setting screens
it handles building and updating the UI
so all you need to do is to find a list
of settings to be displayed to the user
and it also handles interacting with the
Weisse storage so that all so that any
value that the user changes will
alternately get persisted to the device
without you having to worry about it
preferences itself currently exists in
two separate forms first the framework
preference API this has been bundled
with the android framework since the
first version of android so 11 years ago
now since it is part of the framework
any new features and bug fixes we add
only make their way to the newer
versions of android and given that the
design has changed all over the last 11
years as well the framework api is
themed differently depending on which
version of android the device is running
on as a result of these we're no longer
maintaining the framework api and
instead we recommend using the android x
library the Android X preference library
previously known as the v7 and v14
preference support libraries is
unbundled from the framework this means
it can be rapidly updated with any new
features and bug fixes we push the
library itself is backwards compatible
down to API 14 and uses the same updated
material theme across all your devices
this results in a consistent experience
for your users and how does this all
relate to shared preferences you may be
wondering the shared preference API is
allow you to persist key value pairs of
data to the device they used internally
by the preference library to save and
retrieve any values that a user
configures but on actually part of the
library itself just a lower layer
so let's start voting our settings
screen we're going to start off by
voting the simple hierarchy on the right
we have a preference with a switch that
allows the user to toggle state and a
preference that just displays text I'm
going to cover how you should structure
your architecture and also some basic
attributes you should be aware of when
you're using my preference library so
we're going to start at the top with a
simple activity that just acts as the
container for our hierarchy this should
be an app compat activity with an app
compat based theme the activity itself
is basically just a container for this
preference fragment compat which is the
main entry point when using the
preference library all our interesting
preferences and configuration will
happen in here and this fragment itself
just wraps a hierarchy of individual
preferences which can either be defined
in an XML resource or defined
programmatically at runtime in this talk
we're going to focus on XML so the
activity itself is again just a simple
container for our fragment so we just
have some simple fragment boilerplate
and all we need to do here is just show
our settings fragment the fragment again
fairly simple all you need to do is
override this one method oncreate
preferences and then just set up the
hierarchy that you can inflate and show
to the user all the interesting
definition actually happens in the XML
so this is our XML file we start with a
root preference screen object and this
basically is the main container for the
entire hierarchy everything should go
inside of this and they should be the
root element note that you should also
place your preference XML resource files
in the res XML directory so now we can
add our first preference this is a basic
preference it doesn't have anything any
widget associated with it and we have
these three important attributes here
the title and summary are the visual
title and the visual summary actually
displayed to the user on the screen as
you can see on the right and the key is
pretty important for two reasons
firstly if this preference were to
persist any state to the device then
this is the key that the shared
preference instance would use and also
this key allows you to interact with
this preference later on in your life
cycle so it's very important to declare
a key for every preference in your
hierarchy and now we can add a switch
preference comp add this is a type of
preference very similar to before but
now we have a switch widget so whenever
they use a toggle the side of this
preference this will update the boolean
value persisted to
he'd find here now that we've built the
simple hierarchy I'll show you some
other useful features we can add to make
this even better here's the hierarchy
we're going to end up with there's quite
a lot more going on here so we're gonna
take it step by step first I'm going to
cover categories which allow you to
visually split up a complex screen into
groups of similar preferences then
preferences at open dialogues which
allow for more complex configuration
they're just a simple boolean switch I'm
going to talk a bit about dynamic
summaries and also cover dependencies so
continuing from where we left off before
these are the same preferences I had
before just without the rude preference
greentech four verbosity one of these
controls sinking and one just stays
display static information about the
application although this is kind of
simple and Alice or any two things in
that hierarchy the more we add to this
hierarchy the harder it's gonna be for a
user to actually see what preference
does what we can use preference
categories to help separate this up into
logical sub sections to do this we
simply wrap these preference objects
with a preference category tag and as
you can see this now adds an accented
title above these groups again it's
important to set a key and to these so
be correctly persistent state and the
title again same as before same
attribute just displaced lennie
differently next we're going to add an
edit text preference similar to a switch
preference compat in that it's a subset
of a preference this preference uses a
dialog to allow persisting a string
value so when the user taps on this
preference we automatically open a
dialog for you which contains an
editable text field and when the user
taps on okay this value is then
persisted however this gives us some
interesting question what do we set for
the summary here right now there's no
summary so it's quite hard for the user
to see what the current state is and we
would like to show the user what they've
actually saved so they know what they've
done but since this can change
dynamically at runtime we can't just put
a string here the answer here is to use
a simple summary provider this is added
recently in the 1.1 alpha release and
it's part of a broad category of things
we call dynamic summaries I'll cover
more about that later on but this simple
attribute when set to true will mean
that the preference summary will
automatically display either the value
say for the pair
once all the text not said if there
isn't any value said so now we have a
way for the user to set a sync code and
they can see that the value of they've
said automatically however there's one
problem here it doesn't really make much
sense for the user to be able to change
this field if syncing actually isn't
enabled we can use a dependency here to
fix that essentially setting a
dependency allows another preference to
control the state of this preference so
we set the key of the switch preference
compact that will control this
preference so this means that whenever
the switch preference is turned off as
it is here the actual preference is
greyed out and can no longer be
interacted with and when the switch is
turned on the preference returns to
normal and can be interacted with a
hierarchy is almost complete from the
example that we gave the only thing we
now like to do is set a useful summary
for this switch right now enable
periodic syncing is on but what does
that actually mean half we synched
recently maybe there's a problem
connecting to the server so we can use a
custom dynamic summary here to display
to the user when we've lost synced
providing some more useful context in
general dynamic sermons are useful in to
sort of broad scenarios firstly if you'd
like to provide the user with more
context but kind of specific preference
and what it means so in this case we'd
like to tell them when we've lost sync
the device or it can also be useful if
you'd like to display some dynamic
information this could be something like
a version information of your
application or even user information
such as a specific ID or email address
to set as dynamic sir--my we use the
sorrowing provider interface we can use
this to either react to the internal
state of the preference or just use it
as a cool back to generate our in
dynamic summary from external state here
we set the type as switch preference
compact as that is the type of
preference that we're setting the
summary form when the preference is
checked in other words when syncing is
enabled we want to just display that
last time we successfully synced and
otherwise we're just gonna say it's
disabled so it's clear to the user and
this is all they're really assert all we
need to do now is just set this on the
preference so to do that we call fine
preference using the key we previously
assigned in the XML and then we just set
the songwriter this and any other
similar configuration should be done and
uncreate preferences in your preference
fragment compat
and now whenever you the talk was a
satyr the preference the summary will
ultimately be updated based on the
constraints we defined now that we've
build our more advanced hierarchy I'm
going to cover using separate
hierarchies and separate screens
oftentimes you'll want to split up more
complex hierarchies into separate
screens making sure that less important
preferences aren't clearing up your main
screen and making it hard for the user
to focus on the things they actually
want to change if you're already using
the framework API and looking to migrate
there are some different ways you may
have structured your separate screens
and if you're starting afresh with the
Android X preference library you may be
wondering what the best way of having
this is but first let's just recap how a
single screen looks we have our activity
at the top which will internally wrap a
fragment which then contains its actual
hierarchy we can kind of consider the
fragment on the hierarchy to be a sort
of a screen of settings so in reality we
just have an activity which loads a
setting screen which is this and this
works fine when we have one screen but
what if a hierarchy looks something like
this
now on our first screen we have links to
other screens so the sink will link to a
screen of sink related preferences and
messages will link to some more specific
messages relate preferences how does
this look like with our architecture
it's actually very simple to what we've
done previously with a single screen the
initial setting screen would just be
just as before a preference fragment
compat with a hierarchy and then the
sink scanning screen will also be a
reference fragment compact with its own
hierarchy and so on for any other
screens you may have what we need to do
now differently is just the final link
between the synced reference object and
the sync settings fragment so whenever
the user clicks on this preference we
will load the related screen so we'll
sort of in this state pointing to the
initial settings screen when the user
taps of preference now that we've
already defined this link we're just
going to swap out the screen from
underneath and because we're still using
preferences to act as the link the
initial settings hierarchy is going to
be just as we've done before so again we
start with a reference screen tag and we
just have two basic preferences
one for thinking and one for messages
it's important well you may want to add
an icon here to the side of the
preference to provide some more context
to the user as we don't
have an important summary display here
this is just done by defining a durable
with the icon attribute so this will
just be something in your restaurant
and now the only thing left to do is
just to find the links between the
fragments so to do this we use the
fragment attribute and we just set the
fully qualified class name of the
fragment if your fragment is a nested in
a class you'll need to use the dollar
sign to separate the outer class in the
inner class and that's it for the
hierarchy the activity is very similar
to what we have before we just set the
initial setting screen to be displayed
the only difference here is that we
should implement this method on
preference thought fragment this method
is called when a user taps on a
preference it has an Associated fragment
and allows you to customize any
transitions or animations between
fragments there is a default
implementation so if you don't override
this method we will still handle it for
you but you won't have any nice
transitions or animations that you may
want and the fragments are going to be
exactly the same as before again all we
need to do here is just override on
create preferences and set the relevant
XML resource and that's really it now
whenever user taps on the messages or
the sync preferences the chorus fragment
will be automatically displayed to the
user so to wrap some things up we've
recently released 1.1 alpha 1 so please
if you haven't already get it try some
dynamic summaries and other recent
features please follow any bugs in
feature requests to this component on
the issue tracker google.com we've
recently updated the Android settings
guide to make use of the Android X
preference library please check it out
for further information on some of the
things i've talked about in this talk
and some other features out of the scope
of this talk and we're working on
template for android studio as well as
public samples demonstrating this new
library coming soon for more information
on android Jeff Beck you can go to
developer.android.com slash jetpack and
thank you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]